one last pot and I've chosen is because
the immediate racemic of his questions
38% out of the what did I say was out
three three MUX something just for this
to the pot is very hot so what would be
nice to show is or find rather is how
many months in is the minimum number of
months such that the amount left owing
is one hundred eighty thousand what's
the significance of enema it's hot fry
it means that what half left to repay
and we're going to gain some insights
about that in a minute
okay so tell look at part 3 now how do I
go about doing this
what's the setup right the work that we
did prior to this is a huge advantage to
us because yeah we get another color
here is the amount only after and
repayment right and what I want that
should be is less than underneath my
house not okay so therefore he's the way
I'm just gonna start I'm gonna take that
expression am right and I'm gonna let
that be less than hundred eighty
thousand no let's start off by saying
that
I beg your pardon yes I'm glad you asked
that in fact of you remember when you
have a look at the question the first
time you saw there was part one in part
2 and part 2 you had the show you know
right part of the reason why it is there
one of the main reasons is there is
precisely so that even if you screw up
to you can still access three but
importantly that means when you do three
well at least I'm going to use two three
one nine and fifty cents as my M right
that is in fact it is in fact off by one
and a half cents but I'd efficient
experience the agency markers are
trained that if a question has like
prior information provided in it then
they have to be able to monitor this and
this and its resultant ads are
successful okay I'll leave it to you to
work out within that one half cents it's
gonna end up making a difference to out
song in the end but let's see what
happens so there's my M and I had this
big gross fracture
so can we goodbye 231 yeah yeah yeah so
so I'll talk about that in a second
now what I want this to be is less than
180,000 now pause okay I'm solving for n
right now I'm solving for in it's
interesting because any up in the power
right now I only know one kind of branch
of mathematics that will allow me to
solve for something that's in the power
we just spent weeks on it logs right
this is part of why this question was
done so poorly
you've got logs you've got inequalities
in there this is going to be a bit of
mess in order to solve it for the law
what I need to do is get one point zero
zero five to the N and E that is my
subject do you see that so therefore as
we can suggest it I'm going to divide
through by zero point zero zero five and
that's gonna let these one point zero
zero five for the ends and these one
point zero zero five to the end say that
10 times faster it's going to allow them
to collect they'll be like terms does
that make sense
so when you divide through I think this
is what you should get let me check Oh
6:39
Plus
how does that look that look again CG
all I need to do here is collect my
terms
I've got my one point zero zero five two
the engines over here
and then I've got a couple of constant
terms which I want to counter on one
side okay so let's follow that through
and see what happens I'm gonna get minus
- pate
two eight three nine nine but it's also
- oh yes that's right okay so this one
that always there is I almost had my one
point zero zero five to the end as the
subject I just need to divide through
but because I'm going to divide through
by a negative that means my inequality
is gonna change direction so that gives
me this I think I'm going to lose a
couple of zeros while I'm at it